nailed it what are you doing
good buddy it's a beautiful day
oh boy today we're gonna vlog because
jack is coming here he is Jesus Christ
okay he's coming later and I'm gonna see
this bug look at it again seven huh
look at me Dick's a game he's so cute
I'm still waiting for marks yeah so let
me show you my office I had this
Michelle this is Toby
it's a bookcase what did I say what a
what and then I have my B night which
I'm obsessed I'm obsessed with my tea
you guys oh my god what's that okay now
we're heading to the gym Martha's here
and we're gonna pump some iron oh boy
it's gonna be Oh
[Music]
so these become I tied you at these
machines
I see healthy it's that correct you see
my life a super strong I'm pretty proud
of me
[Music]
how many were they get Emma come on come
up need my cup time to start the day
going to the office now
if yours coming with me aren't you
excited cheese size
jump-scare coffee all right today should
be a really fun day I'm heading to the
office now don't worry I'm hands-free
I'm wearing my hands are on the wheel
Michaels set it up so we have four VR
headsets to play with all in the same
room PJ's coming Brad is coming and Jack
is coming and we're all gonna play and
it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome
I'm really excited it's a bit crazy what
we're doing man
so happy I got it so I hate him like
he's so annoying Jesus Christ this is
gonna be crazy all right you'll see more
of that later
I'm really excited this is my office
what the [ __ ] oh yes sleepy took a [ __ ]
on my mousepad yesterday you [ __ ]
[ __ ] sleeping I know the real reason
you're watching this vlog you want to
see sleepy please like we don't take a
[ __ ] I'm I love sleepy so cute but just
don't take a [ __ ] like you did yesterday
oh my god I appreciate that you didn't
take a [ __ ] today I appreciate that
thank you very much he's so chill barely
moving all right guys
what's going on Sippi JPK what are you
doing you're not in the bath you [ __ ]
idiot
well yeah now I got answer emails I have
my own company now rebel mode that's
where I spent most of my time answering
emails like more than a spend time
making videos
[Music]
and I just noticed YouTube for the
second time deleted my thumbnail can you
not delete my artwork that I spent a lot
of time on making problem I'm guessing
it's because it says fuking say bleep
let's just do it let's just do sleepy
all right everyone's happy how dare you
censor my art YouTube unbelievable
alright so now I'm a little bit just a
little bit late I'm going to Gatwick
Airport it's about 35 minutes to pick up
jacksepticeye that Irish [ __ ]
jacksepticeye
welcome to Brighton thank you
it's just like Ireland pretty much city
and cold okay great hey everybody
bye sorry yeah you're not in it anyway
yeah all right we just finished shooting
the VR thing it was very cool did you
guys like it we got to have tits in
space I think that's always a good thing
[Music]
I'm gonna program this shut up
to go over there and then come back to
me I got this here we go come back to me
what the [ __ ] nah let's see you do a
better job jack
let's see you what a [ __ ] idiot am i
right
peace out [ __ ] all right
genius is gonna have to step up here and
show how it's done all right
this is gonna kill it wait for it
oh yeah [ __ ] no you two yeah
[Music]
yeah three second two seconds of glory
this is where the good ideas happened we
would play sleeping with Jesus himself
[Music]
come on turn Hey better pry you came
back to me oh no pity patent go
pit-a-pat oh oh oh [ __ ] okay that's not
weird at all Jesus Christ what happened
to Mickey Mouse what went wrong
what's sad what isn't you have there
wait what's his name great Danny all
right so today we're taking Jack around
Brighton he's having a really good time
oh boy we are now by the pier this is
the best fun everyone's having a good
time
merci oh girl didn't make it awkward you
always do yeah there we go
stay there
shoot hell yeah [ __ ] oh he's back for
my feeling everybody Michael waiver
feelings I'm Jack doing his photo shoot
look at that yeah that's how good I am
that [ __ ] that guy in the [ __ ]
we just found a really funny video Oh
was it funny you know like it was my
nipples are sore
that's all yes I thought you don't worry
about that mai-chan please now we are
playing with the hay that's so [ __ ]
weird do you guys see this yeah yeah hey
that's so [ __ ] weird now we're
playing in the PlayStation VR I hope no
one does anything bad to me while I
don't see anything else I hear you
stop it you have to header it no I'm
just tanking it ok don't eat green
energy [ __ ] hit something with them
anyway we're here in the garage I have a
jacksepticeye but it's not all about the
jacksepticeye it's about knowledge they
didn't mean they're never key a lot more
to come
make sure
[Music]
stop smiling
finally okay we just had some sushi now
we're gonna head back and watch the room
because I don't think what do you know
don't stop kissing me just Michael
please no okay we're gonna watch the
room stop it's gonna be good
haven't seen it okay well let's go
nailed it
what are you doing
hey this log is a bit [ __ ] at this point
isn't it well I didn't really blog that
much I'm going to pick up Jack and then
in a bank later I'm gonna drop that big
shock through the airport I think it was
a really good time Jack if you're
watching this talk but I'm on to you
he's leaving
haha Jack it's been a pleasure thank you
for touching my face my hand is so cold
Cyril don't worry okay just go see you
later I'm kidding alright I hope you
enjoyed this vlog the weekend is over I
had a lot of fun Jack thanks again for
coming over back to making videos just
back to bridges back to the kwinto if
you know this vlog let me know I really
enjoy making them so leave a like I
appreciate it and I'll see in the next
one
as always
[Music]